つい最近まで一緒に遊戯王をやってた人が日本一になってしまいました
肇社長です
おめでとうございますはいみなさん7月7日いよいよ七夕ですねまぁ七夕といえばササ
の葉にお願い事を書いてね短冊をつけて日のって
[音楽]
まあ叶うか叶わないかはわからないですけどまぁお願いごとを滑っているのが結構ある
んですけどその警笛なるといろんなところに短冊を飾る場所があると思うんですよ僕
ここ最近ですね色んなところの短冊を片っ端から観まくって真面目だねことしてる人は
いいんですよすごい真面目で真剣にこう家族のことを祈ったり花壇の無事を祈ったりな
済みなお願いごととかすごい見ててをは
ん
かなって欲しいなって思うんですけどもごくまれに僕までいいですよ
すごいふざけたのがあるもうわざとふざけてるのかそれともミスなのかわかんないん
ですけども僕いろんなチャンスで見てきたんですけどもその中でもちょっと個人的に
これは面白いんだと思った奴を何とか見つけてきたので今回それを紹介していこうと
思いますたまにこうちょっと名前みたいなのが書いてあるのもあったんで
個人名は控えさせてたのでも僕がマッチとかで3つ
keter 面白い短冊ホストホストで紹介しようと思いますでは行こうよはいまずは
こちらですハロウィンが楽しみを得
待て待てというガッツに会とかもちゃんと書いてある種10月30日だからまだずっと
先ですねなんでパパにハロウィン楽しみて書くのかなっていうちょっと人生に面白かっ
た次アンパンマンのような優しい子になりますように
これややになるならこう
どうしたアンパンマンのような優しいことになりますようには良かったんですけど
ちょっと心が割れてしまったのではないでしょうか叶うといいですね
アンパンマンになりますよ次3巻第二期も願いでもないという美香が大好き
はい次
yeah
どうしたどうしたこれそれもこれなんか一枚だけじゃなくてなんか2枚か3枚くらい
あったんですよ
次行ったでやったねやりますやります次お父さんが本物のきつめになって遊びたい
お父ちゃんは狐になることを何よりも願っている男の彼の願いでしたおとうさんぜひ
喫煙になって遊んであげてください
次健康快樂もう海楽求めちゃってますね健康だけの
人は結構多かったんですけどすごいせも快感を求めちゃってるぜ引きも強くなって
ください次
おっぱい入ってました
b 組み合わせ
切る生きてください次だ粉じんになりターンとかなり押しかなり惜しいでしたら小さい
子が帰ったのかな
礼文ちゃまでよかったんですけどそれがなり体位の途中で心がざわめいてしまってるん
ですねファルコンパンツもう技ですねつぎ大丈夫この子からの始まりには君ない
はい早願いことではありませんこれは何だ何か皆さんにこう語りかけたりというか
白上の方の人間の深田かもしれないし以外のようにはみえませんでした次
きれない楽しみがある生き続ける意味だってあるだろう
もうなんかすごいありがたく感じてきました小俣願い活気ある
逆に何かこれ見てなんか勇気もらっちゃったぐらいのやつなんでしょとしても見られる
ことを全然に書いてある短冊かも知れませんありがとうという言葉をありがとうござい
ます次絶対に誰かとか誰が打つから生きるってそういうことだと思う
ちょっっ深いねもうここまでいくと深いですよぜひこの人の願いもちょっと
おくといいですね次文もツールやゲーム待ったゲームマスターになりたい男の子の短冊
ですね
なんかこう英語を習いたてて書いてすごいじゃないと思います
叶うといいねあげました次あるをプール日はコメディアンぱ
一緒にかけていっただから彼はコメディアになりたいみたいですぜひね
お笑い芸人を目指して頑張ってください次 io 2 red 来たーー
医者になりたいんだよね頑張ってねづぎ iot いうサッカープレイヤー
英語で書いてたよいいと思いますなので次 ipod やバッグベルトからってか
惜しい
ため言いたいことはわかります苦労日の空手選手になりたいですよたぶんこの人なんで
本当はブラックベルトからて買って書こうと思ったんですけどブラックを間違えてバッ
クって書いてるんでこれだと私は星にベルト覚えた空手家になりたいになってしまい
ます
me
あっはぁ
というわけで多分更紗なろうと思うそれがあるんですけどもうちょっとパラーと見た
とき
田中インパクトのある3足だなと思ったのがこちらでした
というわけで七夕皆さんどんな願い事をしますでしょうか叶えたいこととかある人いる
と思いますこうゆう丸造形もんでたまにはイイと思うので是非
七夕短冊に願い事を書いてみてはいかがでしょうか結構たんだって見てて
楽しかったのでまたねーか見ながらをそろえた時見つけたら twitter とかで
送ってくださいじゃあ